arguably he was england's best ever
goalkeeper but secretly he had a serious
gambling addiction peter shelton now
admits he lost millions and since
recovering with the help of his wife
steph he now campaigns for stronger
regulation it's got to to a point where
it needs reeling in you know
i mean football clubs and people are
saying well we we can't survive without
betting money but there's a lot of clubs
who can and i think it's a bad business
model if you've got rely on betting
you know for our sport i think we were
talking today um that you know people
are now going to football matches or
watching football and that they're only
interested in what they're bet on you
know all the enjoyments taken out of it
faces from the world of football often
front the adverts pushing people towards
gambling websites but today the
regulator says footballers and
celebrities will soon no longer be
allowed to appear in gambling adverts
former england midfielder paul merson
who's also spoken about his gambling
addiction says adverts on tv are a major
trigger i still think there's a stigma i
think uh i still think that the attitude
of the public is i'll just stop show a
bit of willpower you know stop diarrhea
with willpower let's do that merson now
works at sky sports with colleagues who
currently front gambling adverts
obviously they haven't they haven't they
haven't
they don't know anybody and no one's
touched their lives who who has a
problem and i think it's as simple as
that i think the day that happens i
don't think they'll be doing the advert
if i'm being honest when you delete
these accounts
they'll still email you former youth
player paul pettigrew got hooked on
gambling aged 18. he says the growth of
online casinos linked to sport has
become lethal i think the worst thing
that can happen to anybody is when you
lose
hope and i just completely lost hope
that it would ever get any better and i
was too miserable to live the next 60 70
years feeling the way i was so
i took uh overdose of painkillers and
just wanted it to end i just
completely lost lost hope
the new rules will be in effect in
october in time for the world cup and a
government review is likely to bring
more regulation on the industry later
this year
jason farrell sky news